hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint moins vite
sur messenger et bien jean michel maire
il nous a dit un instant qu'ils avaient
la cote avec anggun et bien on a le
numéro d'un goût nous on va l'appeler
tout de suite là j'étais grisé et on va
bien voir
allez c'est parti alors aux goudes prix
c'est cyril hanouna ma chérie comment ça
va ça va en good tout dérangement syrie
non ça va je suis avec ma fille qu'il ya
un mec dans touche pas à mon poste qui
dit qu'il a la cote avec toi ah ah bon
c'est qui alors on good je vais te dire
c'est jean michel maire qui nous a dit
que tu l'avais chauffée à mort dans
l'émission quand tu étais venu à moroni
souffle qu'est ce qu'elle vous à gauche
vous avez dit que tout allait rendre une
saison mais me tue là bas je crois me
souvenir c'est vrai qu'on avait fait un
gag enfin gag
malheureusement j'ai été la victime
juliette avait remplacé pour me faire un
bisou et à mettre haïti ma vie dit on
est à l'antenne mon mari regarde mais
j'aurais vraiment kiffé tombera c'est
vraiment parce que c'est vrai que tu pas
que tu m'aides situe ma vie dit ça de
façon plus romantiques genre se trouve
très beau don médian est témoin
[Applaudissements]